now I found out that I still had one
video of the let's play park that was 40
minutes long on my PC and that's about
it and I'm pretty much broke when it
comes to the roller coaster cone 3 time
lapses at the moment which isn't because
I haven't been playing roller coaster
kethry
rather I've been playing it non-stop
actually lately I just have many other
projects and stuff that I've been
working on so please forgive me this is
about everything I have this amounts up
to about four minutes of time-lapse
footage of just me trying to get these
details and windows right on this
building but I do have to say hopefully
I can sort of make it up with finally
actually doing a bit of an overview of
the park so we'll get to that in about
three minutes plus and first we just
kind of need to finish this building
which honestly at the like at the end
even of this time-lapse
I wasn't really sure if this was the
final look that I wanted to go with it's
not that I really dislike the building I
think the idea the sort of basic thing
to it is definitely there it is really
just the problem I try to I try to place
those turnstiles by the way but that
just went horribly wrong but it is that
the details that I want to get on it to
really make it look good or just not
there and especially those corner stones
from ralphie's what's that set called I
forgot it but from Robbie's Bieber home
set that is I think this set like an
American house set which has some cool
corner stones in it just doesn't really
work over here since they're quite
logically so I might have to make some
pieces for that as well I really don't
want to make too much because I'm sorry
for all that stuff because I'm lazy and
I kept messing making custom scenery but
then again I'm I feel pretty much forced
to do that for this building I mean
there's only so much that you can mess
with different pieces of scenery and
different details if you just have a
really small building like this because
honestly this building is supposed to
look well sort of large and intimidating
and intimidating but it really isn't
it's pretty damn small and it's gonna be
actually pretty hard to make that work
right but like I said the basic sort of
thing is there and behind this building
that is also something that I really
have no idea yet how I'm going to do it
exactly
have those really beautiful Victorian
glass arches that some stations well
train stations may have I don't know if
you know what I'm talking about but for
those who do those beautiful Victorian
glass arches are absolutely amazing with
like metalwork and nice decorations on
them think about it is though that there
is Bodines girders and glass which you
can use for that but it doesn't really
have the three tile long placement that
I am looking for and it also doesn't
exactly have the sort of details that I
want so I might have to make those two
so that means that there is a lot also
of well at the moment unreal unreleased
stuff in this building some people also
ask me for the the custom serie that's
used for the towers on this building but
I'm very sorry that still being worked
on and not released yet
they'll have to say those basically yeah
decent all right I still could add some
details to it but I actually feel like
it's sort of working out this is
basically the sort of standard Dutch
train station look that most Dutch train
stations have got going I think even the
the National Museum in Amsterdam has it
and I just got interrupted there I don't
know if that's gonna be too obvious in
the video probably yeah but in any case
it's not really standard sort of touch
train station look where you've got
those two towers in a nice fancy thing
in the middle we've all known about this
stuff and have talks about this but
that's basically what I what I want to
do over here which I'm not really too
sure how well it's going to work out but
yeah it can at least sort of try I mean
it's not really been done before too
much and I really do suspect that at the
end I'll just look back at the things
that I've built to cringe heavily and
then just work on stuff and change
details because that's what usually
happens so I shouldn't be too worried
about it yet in any case I see that my
time is almost up for this time lapse so
that's let's jump into the actual
gameplay footage
all right so anyway no I I was supposed
to do that like jumping transition sound
is that even supposed to be I have no
idea I also forgot to turn off bloom
which is absolutely really heavy it's
it's really weird so there we go that's
a lot better this is currently what I
have there is not really that much yet
but then again I haven't really shown it
of real time yet
might as well do that we've got the main
street of course very sexy there is
still some work to be done on the Main
Street though honestly like hey I
probably should show the buildings first
because I before I starts complaining
already I am pretty happy about it
though don't worry but there's
definitely some of these smaller details
that I'm still liking so keep that in
mind like signs and any sign of life
really hahahaha like that's a very vague
ambiguity of the word sign in other case
any signs of that there is actually life
over here is stuff that I still need and
just generally sprucing up this area
using spruces I need to stop the puns
already so I don't know if I really
can't give too many details about each
building this was a little corner
building that I thought like placing
there because because the filling up the
space and it's really small since there
was that that train behind it so it's
supposed to look like somewhat big and
actually like it's not a pillar of space
but it's definitely a filler of space
there and then there's this little house
no idea what exactly it is but it does
it does sort of remind me of area Baltic
sort of architecture I know there's a
there's it's not like a specific sort of
style over here in this area it's like
mixed it's like a mixture of every
single European sort of architecture
style but then generic I've no idea how
it's actually supposed to look to
actually work out but then again I'm
going to say actually way too many times
it does look all right I suppose and
this building over here is a pretty big
building I think I might just turn that
into a gift shop or something fancy it
would be pretty cool maybe a restaurant
but then again I don't have tables
outside I do have tables outside over
here which I just which are honestly
just fillers of spaces well I don't know
what sort of building this even is but
this could be like a Austrian restaurant
or something it doesn't have a bill the
Alpine vibe to it obviously since I use
alpine village but they're moving on
we've also got this building in the
corner which is a pillow and here's the
the the buildings that stick out on the
corners of course pretty damn important
oh this is already a bakery I click oh I
sign for this one but I still could
probably use some like hanging lunches
and fun just fun stuff like that this
building over here is sort of Dutch
inspired ish
sort of like the the brick thing then
it's got going on and the stucco thing
then it's got going on and you like the
top floors no idea how exactly it's
supposed to work out
I should probably actually add some
wooden beams over here is something to
make that look a tiny bit better but
then again there's these small details
can always be fixed it's some like
random buildings over here and then we
go to the other side where we have the
three cameras really funky I probably
shouldn't have been using this like two
restaurants on both sides I used to I
suppose it could be like one restaurant
no idea exactly it's that they're quite
similar really I just wanted to have a
fancy almost symmetrical facade over
here but I really didn't want them to be
exactly identical so that's nuts then
there's this building which is also sort
of Baltic at least it gives off Baltic
vibes to me it's also a bit well it's
very Austrian and with having that
Austrian clock tower on top of it but
other than that it's it's a good little
European building I suppose this
building was supposed to be more of a
Victorian woodwork sort of thing but I
really didn't know where I was going
with that so I suppose it works to fill
up the space of the moments but it's
really not much also I need to come up
with some way to get footage to be
placed on all of these little pillars
because they look cool and alright but
they definitely need some 14 going on
here's probably my what no it's
definitely not my favorite building of
the main street it's just one that is
sort of like the colour scheme a lot
more of than I expected which I probably
should explain a tiny bit since in terms
of colour schemes these building is a
very unorthodox and I would not even
recommend doing it like this for Main
streets since the most common Main
Street sort of way of doing your color
scheme is choose one color for your
accents choose one color for your walls
and choose one color for your roof and
this always me it's almost like I'm some
kind of ice-cream parlor I need to
choose some stuff on how to like
customise your ice cream in any case
that's basically how you normally do it
and either the walls or the accents are
supposed to be white in most cases if
you want your buildings to look good so
this was a bit of a different thing
with having like a beige accents a blue
wall and then a red roof but also the
fact that the bottom walls have
different textures in different colors
than the middle walls and it's a bit of
a mishmash of everything
but in the end it actually sort of works
which is something that I'm kind of
happy about I just realized that the
time is absolutely terrible in terms of
lighting there we go actually gonna make
that a lot less dark
it was very dark at the moment there is
just some more filler really not that
interesting might want to look at that
this building is a bit would be a weird
little Austrian sort of thing I do like
what it's got going on with those arches
and the way it works with the fountain
and the lanterns and stuff and people
and the planters and cool stuff there
but the top floor is still something
that I'm sort of debating if I want to
change it in any way it's just a
repeating woodwork now I'm not too sure
about but overall it's an all right
building and then there's this thing to
little Dutch is looking facades really
not that Dutch although I would say yeah
the right one is something that I'm not
too sure about it's really one of the
buildings which I'm really not sure
oh it's on this on this main square like
most of the buildings I just feel like
alright they can stay but this building
over here I'm just I don't know if I
ever get time and I would feel like
replacing it with something I might just
do that consider placing more fitness
you shut the [ __ ] up and then here is a
little village which is almost identical
to the other falou well not exactly but
it's similar it's got the same sort of
tower thing going on so that was the
main street are young with of course in
the middle that sort of made little pod
thing if I ever got to that that is
still the current planning I would like
to have a trolley which we of course
loop around this area come back there
and then do a some fun stuff around the
main square the main square by the way
is just a little chair swing which I
still need to repair the base of but
that thing has gone absolutely
ridiculous hitbox so I keep removing
that thing and there's some funky
planted stuff going on around that
really not much yet since I still need
to place all the buildings around this
and then the first area is the Spanish
area which is as of now still very
incomplete because I'm just missing
these facades over here which really
does make quite a bit of a difference
and I would like some more details on
this as well as the little restaurant
that really also needs some signs of
life like it just a little sign saying
that there's a restaurant over there at
least it has ice cream over there and
some planters and stuff is a things that
I really want to have maybe even like
I don't know drains things like that
just do very small accents that make it
look a tiny bit more realistic is it
right then actually quite happy about
how it turned out I mean it took I think
this was the third thing that I did on
this spot and it was finally something
that I felt okay about to actually keep
it which is the the teacups a very small
variant I did get a comment saying yeah
teacups aren't really it's probably a
better thing for the English area which
is also something that I want to do but
this is a small sort of teacup right so
the big teacup ride will be in England
well I suppose people in the
Mediterranean area like see well who
doesn't
but yeah I couldn't really find any
Mediterranean sort of thing and then
there's cool little city facades here
very inspired by Madrid especially this
building over here I still want to work
a tiny bit on this water by the way and
just city facades this thing needs to be
finished as well though don't worry
though there will be windows in this
building and yeah that's pretty much
that stuff little flat right over here
which I'm considered I'm considering by
the way to turn this flat right also
into building because basically looking
over here you've got the nice little
boulevard and there's just so much of a
folio of a gap over here which is being
spamed with foliage which I'm not too
sure about if I really like it that way
so I might get back to that and and
there's the log flume which can also
still need you some more details but I
think that with the little town facade
over here it does start shaping up
pretty nicely and I am quite happy about
that this facade by the way came out a
lot better than I expected only one very
sad thing about this was that I think I
spent like a couple of hours trying to
make a tower for this little Church over
here and in the end just ended up with
removing all of that and just going with
a two minute solution which I think it's
still the best-looking thing so yeah
that's that and the station of this
thing is really strange story I started
over something that was very much based
on the City Hall Madrid including huge
towers and everything but then again it
was really way too big and it was almost
immersion breaking it just broke the
rest of this area so removed the towers
and now this is what I'm left with and
that's pretty much that's it
does have a really bad Arabian vibe well
not really bad Arabian vibe but pretty
strong one but I don't know I feel all
right about that since it is Spanish we
which does have the Arabian stuff going
on and here's the little building with
the clock that I still need to fix since
it has a band render distance and it
disappears over here
it's not too bad but I like the clock
too much to remove it or keep it like
this I definitely need to make that
thing
let's Poli have you / stick out more and
yeah that's pretty much it I think well
we've got the bridge which is alright
but it still needs some stuff around it
and then there's the Dutch facades over
here which is still a very much a WIP
and the train station future thing which
I want different cornerstones forward
because the cornerstones are kind of
ruining it at the moment but yeah that's
pretty much it's that now there's also
really big like planning fields and this
all looks like really weird in this
stuff and basically how that's all gonna
work out is these are gonna be different
areas the lights grouse is gonna be the
England area which I'll still extend
into that direction as well this area is
can be a small German area which I would
also like to have and yeah this is going
to be the Alpine area at least that's
the current planning then over here I
can put the Romanian then I think over
here Baltic then maybe Russian as a
small transition to the Japanese name
because otherwise I feel like it's way
too soon and Russian does have that
layer to wood stuff in their buildings
and stuff so that could be very good and
that's pretty much it yeah really
there's not too much else that I can say
I think it's just a time to start
streaming and Billy's a aquapark because
that's what I'm doing at the moment by
the way yeah I am finally building a
water park and yeah that's also fun so
thank you guys for watching and I'll see
you guys in the next episode which
should be again a normal time lapse as
always so bye